(Pewds imitating jacksepticeye)
Top of the morning to ya laddies.
Today, it's the only sunny day that we would ever get in UK.
So I decided
I'm just gonna vlog it
and take some time off from the COMPUTER
I'm also wearing shorts.
I know
Very nice
Marzia have been wanted to buy uhh one of those kiddie pools
for a long time and I'm kind of like that's a bit trashy, but it sounds fun
Marzia: Excuse me?!
So we're gonna buy a pool today
to really enjoy the British summer
For those of you who don't know. This is my temporary setup
I'm a- are kind of like summer location and this is pretty much the same setup I have
As I brought to Japan. It all fits in a- in a suitcase
Setup tour~
This is the...
this is the camera I got in Japan.
uh- this one is 4k so which is why sometimes you see all my pores
*giggles*
In case anyone is curious
this is for the sound.
Usually you see every Youtuber ever have like the squares on the wall
The thing is you have to spray those with like this is glue and I used to have that in my old setup
They don't go away from the wall
If you ever put them on the wall once
They're gonna be there forever, and I'm like, I don't want to do that again
So you just get these babies
Look who it is? (EDGAR!)
How are you sleeping in this bed?
Awwww <3
Edgar: I wuv u, Felix
and I wuv ur penis
You guys wanna see something cute?
Edgar: Oh yeah, film me
No. Not you, Edgar.
Come here
Thank you, Maya. For cleaning
(laughs)
Byee!
Awwww~ I'm sorry
sorry
*bonding moment with Maya*
*Edgar interrupts*
Hey, look who always wants attention.
Just found the vacuum. How the hell did it get there?
(Cyberlife, Pewds. The androids are ALIVE)
Which one should we get?
Marzia: That's maybe the only option
I think that's fine, honestly
-What is this?
nah
What about the gladiator game?
No, but there was one thing
This looks so bad
(water balloons)
Okay, we can get this
Marzia: Yeah?
Oh my god. Marzia, you just made a mess
*tries to tidy it*
*makes it worse*
Oh my god!
It's gonna be me and you
Marzia: uh-hmm
Can't wait
Marzia: Me and Edgie and Puga (Maya)
Oh my god, guys.
Please
relax
*kiddie pool abuse*
I forgot to buy a pump.
You're gonna help me blow Edgar?
*Edgar: intense panting*
I even remember in the shop, I need to buy a pump
(nice job Poods)
*Blows hard*
*Blow some more* (Swedish Bane)
Okay, so what if I fill the waterbed- I mean this water thing with water?
HmmMmmMmmm
You know Bill Gates has the famous quote that he'd rather hire
lazy people
cause they'll figure out a smart solution to a
problem.
This is how we do it
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No problem.
As you can see
Marzia, we have a problem (you just said NO PROBLEM)
marzia: yeah?
We have a problem the robot. Shoosh! Go away!
Marzia: Oh NOOOOO
*hits Pewds*
Go somewhere else
Okay, you do the camerawork.
Oh god, it's coming back. It's back for vengeance
Please don't hurt me
Honestly, I'm scared.
(My name is Connor. I'm the android sent by Cyberlife.)
Yeah, that's right. Oh, no.
Don't pick up the... Ok, stop
Why swim in the water when you can swim around the water? (million dollar idea here)
Marzia (Uh-hmm?) I just discovered something
*flips kiddie pool*
This time...hahaha
(good job Pewds)
What is this? (What?) Why is there a hole there?
So, ah yes, I may have been blowing inside the hole that's meant to release the water...
Whatever
(Intense blowing)
(Group blowing)
(More blowing)
Sure glad Bill Gates is watching.
Let's build it up, baby
Don't you dare
(The queen giggles)
(wets The King of nine year olds)
*slides close*
NO.
So Edgar is terrified of water
But if it, I think he's just scared of waves
Is this is your favorite song?
Yup
(hype song starts playing)
I feel good about me
(DANCE PARTY!)
It's so good (The queen approves)
Stop it!
Okay, we're gonna even the odds a little bit
Do you think it's a bad idea to put boiling water?
Should be fine
(ohh so muscular)
You know, Youtubers, they flex with their pools
*continues pouring hot water*
...This is what I got
Ohhhhh, so nice
Put um- more water please
LeEpic prank on girlfriend time. This is gonna be lit guys. Oh my god
That's pretty neat. Look at that
Like little titties.
That's pretty cool actually. Look at that
Look at that
*proceeds to drop one*
AHHHHHHHHH!!!!!
You.. B-eehhh (family friendly Felix, guys)
*Marzia shrieks*
*evil laugh*
I have all the ammo you know. (Marzia: You hit me!)
Did I hit you?
How?
I hit your butt? (Yeah)
Oh, I got the title for this video now.
Hey, Maya -No...
Hey, Maya. (No...) Oh, she doesn't see any more. She's getting more blind.
HEY MAYA *fake throws water balloon*
Okay, catch. *throws*
*explodes*
Pff-hahahaHAHA
Is it hard? (that's what she said) You're usually really good at catching
Marzia: It's very s-
slippery? *perfect catch*
no no No NO NO!
Oh wow, it's so hard (ehehehehe *wiggles eyebrows*)
(Pewds trying to juggle his responsibilities like-)
Ok. The water should be a lot hotter now
Yeah, it's pretty nice actually
We're doing a-
(Oh, it's nice!) I told you
We're doing a photo shoot for Maritza.
What's your name again?
-Yup
Mat-sa-sas? (wtf)
*pops*
You know, I was the number one goal keeper
*catches*
(Edgar dies)
[ W A S T E D ]
(Dying walrus)
My child, my cherished (some Swedish word)
Edgar loves the water so much
*Edgar whines*
Right, Edgar?
(Edgar: Let go of me you peasant)
*slowly lowers Edgar*
He's looking for an escape
Awwwww :3
(Swedish) Good boy Edgar
That's not too bad
Yeah
It's's not too bad (Papa Poods on duty)
(Swedish again) Good boy Edgar
Wanna get Maya as well?
Destiny is merciless
awwwww <3
She floats. She's so fat oh wait (Excuse me?)
Good girl
She doesn't mind
*in a cute voice* You're so cute
Edgar, you wanna go in again?
*Intense panting* (Edgar: NO)
*in Stitch voice* I don't like it one bit.
Get me out
(they're like a family. so cute <3)
Oh my god, he's crazy. What is he doing?
Got you now~
*adorable Edgar sneeze*
Edgar: What is happening?
Okay, slow-mo shot. This is gonna be epic, guys
[brought to you by Slo Mo Guys]
[intense action]
[balloon popping]
[Majestic]
[Sensational]
[Expectation Fail]
You can't tell but I'm so incredibly sunburned.
I feel it
*hisses in pain*
Very nice, very nice. Oh, yeah.
Ohhhh yeah.
I don't know- albino bug
or is it just painted to the wall?
I've never seen that
I can't believe you notice that.
(to the bug) you're such a- creep
Ok. Alright, buddy
Alright. Ok. Ok. Alright
[Capture Success]
I feel like- What do you do?
Just let it go?
(Marzia approves)
[iS tHiS a pIgEoN?] (insert overused meme)
He's not a very good flyer
Adventures with Pewdiepie and Marzia
(and you're watching Disney Channel)
Bug catching
Marzia, do you think I'm able to put on the wall?
[hype song]
In case you're wondering it's going- it's going great.
It's going so good. Marzia thinks it's not straight
Well
Not everything in life is perfect. Okay, and that's not my fault.
I messed up guys, I messed up.
Alright. TV on the wall
Haters will say it's Photoshop
What do you think Edgar?
Edgar: Someone please adopt me
If you guys ever need help to hook up your TV
I do installments
YouTube revenue...
It's very low, please guys. So any tip, will greatly be appreciated
I'm willing to travel
across country
install your TV for a cheap price
of 399
We've officially peaked in this vlog.
It's not gonna get any more interesting than me putting up a television.
There's nothing to vlog
(Sh!t running out of content)
I'll probably do some reading. Reading Starship Troopers
It's really good. It's nothing like the movie, but I really like it.
Good old relaxing day off. Thank you for joining me
I hope you enjoyed this VLOG if you want more vlogs, you know what you got to do
You know what you got to do. You got a thumbs down this video everybody. That's right
We do opposite style on this channel
We're edgy. We're cool. We're hip.
Please like the video, please. I'm just jo- *Brad cuts the video*